brought to you by msi computers msi
number one in gaming find out more at us
msi com let's talk about let's go to hit
man before we hit the japanese games and
i go crazy let's talk about hit man so
hit man uh this is huge because it's
going to be completely different
structurally to not just a previous
hitman game is but really any kind of
game i've seen before it's almost like
an episodic hitman game yes a app didn't
use the word episodic because i think
that has connotations that aren't really
appropriate for this oh yeah um what's
going to happen is there is a digital
release which contains a whole bunch of
assassination contracts but they're
going to continually add new contracts
new environments new gameplay mechanics
are since the games won't you so now
what that means is it plays into the way
hitmen is structured around a kind of
mission based system so it's basically
like you're going to be having new
missions over time and it's almost like
this is going to function as a platform
for just hitman game yeah yeah going
forward I think that's why they're just
calling it hit man absolutely I think
that's just taking it back to the
essence of what it is just hit man you
know your back with your assassination
agency it's kind of back to how you were
in the first one and I wonder what that
means for the story I mean it's kind of
like the hit man's story isn't a big
deal but it does have enough of an era
even enough law for people to care about
it so kind of cutting that off and
detaching from that could be kind of
something that upsets a lot of longtime
hitman phone well the game launches on
December I 2015 getting press release
the press release said the narrative
concludes in 2016 oh yeah cool stories
going to be in the base game that you
buy I'm going to have to play it along
you know the next few months I really
like the idea of them releasing these
episodic hitman contracts because it
gives them the opportunity to really
cross something unique each time and
people have been clamoring for that
blood money style kind of emerging and
figuring stuff out your own way and
killing someone the way you want to and
then this was present in hitman
absolution as well you play a created
contract system but this the contracts
are back in this but it's not just them
it's also contract from the developers
as well with entirely new content
hmm sorry laughing at that guy getting
accident yeah um so it seems like from
it looks like from what we have seen in
this game that it's sort of getting a
complete overhaul some might say a
reboot I'm not so sure that hitman is a
franchise that needs to be rebooted what
do you think Evan I feel like the last
game was a reboot in a sense I don't I
mean I did you know you're at a stage in
this I think with this game in this
series where you can almost do anything
you want regardless you can you said it
anywhere you want you can go all around
the globe all that you need is is agent
47 you need the bald guy with you know
with the symbol on his head and that's
all you need so I don't know in a sense
you know you could call this reboot to
me it just seems like another hitman
game I don't think it really needs to be
a reboot but it's it feels like an ice
bath after absolution I'm gonna wash
that away I feel like the Hitman series
has been kind of in recent times been
struggling to find what its identity
really ever since it kind of they were
forced to take it beyond the pc and
become something that needs to be
refined in kind of palatable for console
gamers it's kind of struggled to find
where it is an absolution was like a
more Splinter Cell kind of focused type
game with some of the trimmings of what
makes hitman unique whereas this is kind
of like going back to the the early days
of hitman was just providing these small
sand boxes for players do solutely here
and it's going to be interesting to see
how the console market reacts to that
whether they enjoy or whether they kind
of find it a bit too wishy-washy or two
hands off for them absolutely yeah well
I'm very excited December 8th we're
getting it very soon about half a year
let us know what you think of the new
hitman in the comment in the comments
and we not be nice yeah please be nice
but yeah hitman super good be root don't
be rude don't be
you